so a lot of people are hitting the chat
and pressing F but I just got a weird
notification saying that we couldn't
live stream
really yeah that's freaky we couldn't we
couldn't live well right yeah we should
be live now we are live what everybody
presses F cuz they're like you're not
here literally at the moment eight
o'clock starting yeah so um things are
pretty crazy today
but what else is new yeah I'm Tim that's
Adam welcome to chez whatever we do have
the invisible Lydia Whiterun yeah there
she is
Lydia of Whiterun and to hold all of my
items what what day are we on of the
leckrone apocalypse I don't know lock in
our basement is like our 29th show it's
like a 28 you know like the only other
news I saw was that parent like Westwood
West West world West West world yeah
right man West world is back and people
isn't actually back II already I guess I
don't know I saw the new this return
like all of a sudden people in care
about coronavirus for a belief it was
like once like bit of static in the in
the grid and I was like it's a good show
that just what I did diving yeah the
second season but I do have I do have an
important update today oh man our cat
bucko went into my room and decided to
knock the iron out the ironing board and
then go to sleep
boku because the the iron was in the way
so he knocked it off and we heard this
bang we're like what happened and we go
up there and he's just laying in the
spot looking at us like a smug
sharpening Rayquaza
oh man quarantine life so anyway the big
the big story is that well this I guess
the feminists wrote a story from the
Atlantic the coronavirus is a disaster
for feminism and it's not the first time
we've seen stories like this where
feminists when there's a disaster or
something related to conflict crisis
when all of a sudden feminists change
their tune yeah not completely it's not
like they're saying no equality but all
of a sudden they're challenging the true
notion of equality because they don't
want equal responsibility and I'm not
saying all feminists can't make sure
that's clear cuz there's obviously gonna
be a bunch of feminists you know
Christina Hoff Sommers is a factual
feminist jeez what is she second wave
yeah she's
besos Camille Paglia yeah so these are
feminists who believe in real equality
okay and then you have what are we on
fourth wave now is that
intersectionality I don't even know
anymore does it there's a big numbers
like fourth edition yeah yeah it's like
we're on the fourth push out of a new
feminism it's very different what really
is different not this but these people
are the hardcore like Equalists
everything must be the same no matter
what and their Tunes change the moment
things start falling apart so let's do
this okay if you're just tuning in
hit hit up the superjet if you want to
swear your comments but I will admit as
the viewership grows we will have to
start speeding through and prioritizing
the super chats and then we just start
you know we typically go for the ones
that are in bigger amounts but we really
do try to hit them all we do it and and
you know periodically periodically Adam
will try and grab for the regular chat
as well but also make sure to join if
you haven't already want to support the
show click the join button down below or
go to youtube.com slash Tim cast IRL
slash join to support the show subscribe
notifications all that good stuff let's
just uh let's start talking about this
the coronavirus is a disaster for
feminism pandemics affect men and women
women differently like I'm gonna be
honest I don't really care about our
opinion I'm not sure if I want to
actually read through this but we can
just go through the gist of what she's
saying
and it's it's basically that you don't
you want to give us the gist like she's
saying that because women do the
housework and our society is relied on
it so basically what she's saying is
that governments get a lot out of women
because women do stuff like take care of
old people and families so you know the
things that women are like built custom
built to do the government is taking
advantage of what child-rearing right by
allowing them to do that especially in
times of national dress like this now
here's the interesting thing
hmm there may be many feminists or
progressives who would say women are
designed to do it's like women actually
can feed babies yeah wide hips that are
many differently men technically can
there's this is true
that apparently like dudes have the
ability to make milk just not really
gonna happen yeah I mean so so you know
look I'm a fairly progressive individual
myself but I think what we're seeing a
lot of today is fofo progressivism and
faux feminism yeah where it's just a
buzzword
I think the
people have found a path to power and
it's through our goodwill and so they
pretend to be all of these things about
libera libera equality and they exploit
the system for their authoritarian
agenda which is revealed when trouble is
afoot make sense so here so here's what
basically happens look we are not a
perfectly egalitarian society where men
and women are at you know equal footing
like men are still predominantly CEOs
and there's there's you know biological
reasons for it all of a sudden were
faced now with a global pandemic the
coronavirus right and this does not care
about what you think it will it will
come for you you will get sick and
you'll be put in hospital so we have a
story here let me show you this from the
New York Times younger adults make up a
big portion of coronavirus
hospitalizations data showed nearly 40%
of patients sick enough to be
hospitalized were aged 20 to 54 but the
risk of dying was significantly higher
in older people as a couple things you
got to consider there what they're
basically saying is young people respond
better to ventilation what they're also
saying is that we are because of that we
are keeping the mortality rate for young
people low through hospitalization which
is while that flatten the curve stuff is
so important I'm you know so I don't
want to make this as of this big thing
on coronavirus necessarily it's about
feminism what ends up happening in any
big disaster is that all of a sudden
notions of civil rights and similar
civil liberties get suspended period
Trump just enacted the defense
production Act he can now literally just
press the button and change the economy
he can literally go to Elon Musk and say
make ventilators yeah now a lot of these
companies aren't naturally saying you
got it boss like because we all know we
got a pitch in for the war effort we got
a serious pandemic on the globe yeah all
of a sudden reality takes foot so I'll
put it this way the corona virus is a
bit different I mean it's not a 1 for 1
comparison to say war or something but
no sane person like if imagine there's a
guy and his wife and they're in a house
together and then all sudden they hear
like someone break in who gets up it's
always a dude why would it be the woman
yeah and I'm not saying the woman can't
no I would I would get up and but the
woman could if she wanted to stay stay
here let me go check this out yeah at
2:00 a.m. the woman gets up with a baby
the man gets up for the robbers but
there's a really
reason outside of ideology like you
wouldn't get up to go check on the
robber because you're like I'm a man
right it's because typically the men are
taller and have more fast twitch muscles
right more bone density it's all that
matters if you're in a right
relationship and the dude was a tiny
little dude and the woman was like 6
foot 3 in super ripped I'm sure she
would get up and be like wait here yeah
but most men it's so I think I think it
was maybe one of the wine Stein's who
said this like that if you want to see
the true
you know biological diversity or
difference between men and women just
tell everyone in a room to line up
tall's to shortest and what will you see
most of the man one side most women the
other side and a little mix in between
that ratio in its on its by itself means
that dude you can be the biggest
feminist in the world but when when you
know the Bandidos come a-knockin it's
typically gonna be the guy who gets up
so here's here's the thing here's the
point about like this coronavirus stuff
again a pandemic is really different
compared to say like war but or robbers
coming into your house
robbers go in your house right but
crisis doesn't care about your your
equality so all of this equality exists
because we've secured a big bubble we
live in the secure state where we've got
military bases all over the world nobody
messes with us right sometimes they do
we've been we've been through some stuff
but for the most part you then have good
times I guess what do we have to worry
about man yeah poor people in this
country of airconditioning
not crazy so it's really interesting to
me that we ended up in this world with a
ridiculously high stock market low
unemployment everything was just getting
better and better and it seemed like it
was already great have you ever seen
that louis louis c.k bit where he talks
about how everyone's always complaining
but everything's better than it's ever
been yeah yeah yeah it's amazing yeah
you get all these lefties who complain
about how bad everything is when it's
literally never been better right
did you know that you have better dental
care than rockefeller did when he had
the biggest monopoly on the planet no I
didn't recha sky in the planet yeah
because it was 1900 something yeah so
now you've got a microwave he couldn't
make can of beans that fast I need to
hire somebody to do it you know he could
hire ten people probably did yeah a lot
of people to make us beans for me so now
so basically what ends up happening is I
think when you look at another good
example of this and then actually want
to jump to another really good example
of how famine
doesn't work in a crisis but you have
these these Ilhan Omar progressive
praising Donald Trump she said she was
in unison with the president all of a
sudden these people who have nothing but
disdain for the president flip and now
start supporting him Trump just it
announced his plan to close the southern
border to migration where's all the
naysayers yeah not a crisis not a crisis
they're like whatever you say buddy
you're the boss survival all of a sudden
these people who before were saying like
I should be in charge are now scared
saying please protect me and and it's as
true of guys - they're like Trump you do
it
Joe Scarborough for instance MSNBC we
got to support the president so the
coronavirus will be interesting right
now we've got a bunch of people staying
home and now more than ever people to
take care of each other so that's what
the point she's you know kind of making
let me just read this she says enough
already when people try to be cheerful
about social distancing and working from
home noting that William Shakespeare and
Isaac Newton did some of their best work
while in England while England was
ravaged by the plague there is an
obvious response neither of them had
children childcare responsibilities
Shakespeare has spent most of his career
in London where the theaters were while
his family lived in the Stratford upon
stratford-upon-avon during the plague of
1606 the playwright was luckily lucky to
be spared in the epidemic his landlady
died at the height of the outbreak and
his wife and two adult daughters stayed
safely in the Warwickshire countryside
Newton meanwhile never married or had
children he saw out the Great Plague of
1665 1666 on his family's estate in the
east of England and spent most of his
adult life as a fellow at Cambridge
University where his meals and
housekeeping were provided by the
college for those with caring
responsibilities an infectious disease
outbreak is unlikely to give them time
to write King Lear or develop a theory
of optics a pandemic magnifies all
existing inequalities I mean she agrees
with me it sounds like that's true yeah
even as politicians insist this is not
the time to talk about anything other
than the immediate crisis working from
home in a white collar job is easier
employees with salaries and benefits
will be better protected self isolation
is less taxing in a spacious house than
a cramped apartment but one of the most
striking effects of the coronavirus will
be to send many couples
back to the 1950s across the world
women's independence will be a silent
victim of the pandemic now we can see in
my opinion the ego of feminism and I'm
gonna give you the best example y'all
ready for this
go ahead yeah I'm a feminist and I'm
against the new draft proposal and it's
not for the reason you think it seems
like every year one of these politicians
says it's about time we drafted women
and now that women are eligible for
combat it's about time we drafted women
for combat and then what do you end up
seeing whoa whoa whoa I didn't sign up
for that kind of feminine not exactly
yeah let me show I got some check us out
so a little bit let me start by saying I
don't know if these tweets are real okay
it's just an image that pops up on
Google and here's what it says I don't
want equality no I suddenly don't want
equality the Senate approved a bill to
require women to register for the draft
the draft should be outlawed
I don't want equal rights like this I'm
willing to bet some of these are fake
yeah like you know you'll get some
trolls right but the point is we have an
article written by you know for the
Odyssey online where it basically says
you know what you pull this up Adam
what's what's the gist of it's like well
she's saying that feminism here it is
feminism for me which I admit may not
share everyone who shares this label is
all about choice women should be given
the choice to do what they want to do
with their lives so but but I guess men
shouldn't if it is the draft because the
draft is your chosen and it's a go fight
you have no choice so we're gonna put
you in jail yeah so we don't have a
choice as men but this is the funny
thing how is that evil even this right
here look at this this is the narcissism
of a feminism then it's gonna send many
couples back to the 50s and women's
independence will be a silent victim of
the pandemic you know man I understand
we're all young United and women are
stuck at home right now no no it's it's
complicated it's worse than that right
yes everyone's independent but you know
what 80% of the homeless are men I
didn't know that number but you will end
up seeing these ads they they play where
it's like you know one in five homeless
people are women we must end women's
homelessness and it's like you mean to
tell me that 80% of the homeless are
dudes
well yeah isn't that the bigger problem
yeah it's interesting because during the
the whole black lives matter all lives
matter like conflict yeah there was this
comic that shows a house burning that
says black lives matter and his house
burning and there's a house with a
little bit of fire catching on it and
there's a white guy holding the hose
spraying his house that's only burning a
little bit and he says but all lives
matter and the point they were making
was like shouldn't we pay attention to
the bigger fire well if that were true
they'd be focused on male homelessness
you can see this from her perspective
she's like you mean I'm not gonna be
able to go and do whatever I want
think about the draft so women get to
stay home get to stay home while men
literally go die right but her and her
thing is like we're not going to be
independent anymore it's not about
equality it's about we are we giving a
getting a choice to do what we do with
our lives it's like but that's not what
the draft is that draft is not a choice
you have to go fight it it's not right
the issue is that you know a lot of the
the mentality around modern feminism is
that it only affects me like they don't
stop to think for two seconds that men
are affected in ways - yeah exactly but
then when it comes to you know men's
issues they immediately plot the same
card where it's like men are being
forced to hide their emotions and stuff
like that and they call anything else
toxic masculinity yeah so it's always
about their perspective instilling their
you know their way of life that is such
a dirty trick because women want men to
be like them so when men act like men
that's toxic masculinity they want them
to act like women like what is the point
why would you even bother having more
than one's faith thank you I don't I
don't think it's real it really is I
think they're just saying with the
thinking it would they think they need
to say to fit in nice I think there is
some truth in that in what that women
want men to be like women but why
they're not attracted to it they're
really not I don't get it I don't get it
either but I think there is some truth
in it though they want just like we just
want men are different men act different
you know it's not a DHD that the kid has
a lot of energy cuz he's a guy and we
need to blow off steam and fight and
wrestle and what that's what I did as a
kid why you know well so you know like I
can imagine like a
college party and then the dudes are
like drinking then one doodle punch his
friend in the arm like joking and all
laugh and then the other final give a
friend of noogie or something like that
right or they're literally wrestle fight
like I had friends growing up where we
would we would have we actually fought
for fun like we've been apart he would
be like yo you know like I don't know
you get drunk and then we have we
playfully fight maybe get hit a little
bit not hurt too bad and then we laugh
and have some drinks yeah we'd just mess
around like you know we would skate we
would get hurt and so the question then
is none of the women were doing that
like no one told them and they couldn't
punch each other - right what's up with
that yeah I never saw any groups of
friends that fought that were all girls
that would be weird did you ever fight
never wanted to know
girls fight they do it because they want
to win and it is not been actually hurt
them yes you need to sharpen your nails
yeah no yeah it's not good I've been a
being to fights that were actually like
real fight yeah real fights yeah you
know and it's like I didn't want to be
this right in that situation right but
I've fought with all of my friends all
the time but right no not like I'm mad
at them but like wrestling so let's but
let's go to the ground whatever let's
take this line and she says across the
world women's independence will be a
silent victim of the pandemic well I
agree 29 funny enough this pandemic is
men are more susceptible to it yeah
exactly so women actually have it better
she she's like that's not that big a
deal she just moved right on it
literally says it right here
yeah the chronal virus appears to affect
women less severely but in the past few
days the conversation by the pandemic
has broadened we are not just living
through a public health crisis but an
economic one uh-huh okay so so but there
was there was another article that went
viral among a lot of I think a lot of
conservative types of sharing it where
it said men more likely to you know face
severe after you know issues with
complications women most infected yeah
but let's let's listen I want to make a
clear point here she's saying women's
independence will be a silent victim so
what men don't want to be around their
kids so when when when this when when
we're now facing a global pandemic the
man still has to provide for the family
and that's a good thing
like are you saying you don't want to be
around your kids that's because
yeah pretty sure the dad would love to
spend time with their kids yeah
especially to finally have a couple
weeks where they have to another like
this is cool and I can you know play
ball with my kid or go to some art or
something play music I I don't
understand this it's it's narcisse's it
makes me feel like she doesn't have a
family that she cares about maybe I can
actually I can actually not mind it very
easily assuming you know there is a
certain kind of person that that is
attracted to high-profile media jobs
narcissists so okay do you think she
represents the majority of women I would
say absolutely not definitely not I'd be
willing to bet there were like you know
divorce courts and like chattin Family
Court's overwhelmingly favor women okay
yeah yeah most like the that's this
that's the stereotype where they're
right or wrong that's you know whatever
but I'm willing to bet they are
substantially on average more women who
would say I'd rather be with my children
and more men who would rather say I'm
gonna go you know get the job done and
go do some work but it doesn't mean men
don't want to be with their kids it also
doesn't mean that women don't want to be
independent right but this is kind of
like media feminism we see we're all
sudden they're like whoa whoa whoa the
draft no we don't want equality now it's
because they're only saying these things
in the in public to get power and access
and attention they're narcissists they
want everyone to see them and know their
name yeah so it actually comes down to a
real threat all of a sudden they're like
whoa whoa like you don't see women going
around screaming like demanding rights
to you know wait around in sewers to
clear you know blockages or like you
know work as garbage people
garbage persons ya know it's always
about getting the like the corner office
air-conditioned you always been the
garbage man to me yeah right I mean like
we're in a new era man 95 persons I have
diversity or garbage email garbage man
yeah it's always my reach woman every
place I've ever been
that's always been yeah I've been all
across this country
I've lived in Europe for a while there
in Europe they are in Europe I think I
don't know I've never seen it I'm just
saying I've never seen it and you see do
you ever watch Parks and Rec a couple
times you see this episode well anyway
they're fighting for equality and
they're the garbage guys are like you
couldn't
this job and then they were like oh well
we're gonna prove you wrong oh yeah and
they basically did it but then the it
was you know it's clearly a show but
then I couldn't lift something write it
all it boiled down to them going well we
can't lift this into the truck yeah
exactly how I picture that pattern oh
yeah derp yeah man you know it's crazy I
think you know one of the things that a
lot of what really exacerbates this in
youth mm-hm is that like a ten year old
kid a ten year old girl aren't gonna
have a big disparity between their
strengths and physical ability it's
there it is yeah prenatal testosterone
does have a big impact and go which is
why we saw 12 year old do the first-ever
1080 pretty sure it was it was like a
twelve year old he was 12 I think the
the first ever 1080 was done by like
maybe it was 14 I was 10 not know maybe
on what like a snowboard or no no on a
skateboard
this one this recent that just happened
no no that's a 1260 oh I'm pretty sure
that was I think it was Mitchie Brusco
or or I think was made you look it up
yeah did first he date him 900 he was
like when he was younger yeah oh and
then he did it and then he did it fakie
1080 when he was like 12 or something
ridiculous is it the same guy who did
the 1260 I don't think so 560 was cool
so I got this dude who did the first
1260 better than T Brusco right was the
first 1080 1080 let me see the 30 I
started skating when he was 3 right so
listen listen of course yeah there are
rising
there are skateboarders who are male and
female mhm and you know so here's the
point I'm trying to make when you're a
lot a lot younger you don't notice for
the most part that strength disparity
but man once you become an adult you
like seriously yeah me open the pickle
jar for me or chop some wood yeah oh
yeah one swing I could chop it I know
it's ridiculous yeah so did you find it
it was Tom's shower I'm sure yeah and he
was sorry accident on video yeah he oh
man the comments are well he was 12 he
was 12 oh well years old 12 years old
amazing I like look now I got no beef
I'm not trying to disrespect anybody I
have a lot of some friends who are like
top level female pro skaters they're
cool yeah there's some vitally good if
it really is
about like puberty as they say then why
you know why is it that there's no 10
year old female doing nine hundreds or
ten ''tis because he's more than
skateboarding has predominantly been a
guy sport don't know all sports have
yeah true you know but we're talking
about skateboarding right now so
specifically I mean I taught
skateboarding for a while and I would
say 90% of the students I taught were
guys of course but go back to the 60s
and they were there were women
skateboarding true because skateboarding
wasn't that much of a developed sport as
it is today right so what made dudes
actively pursue and push the boundaries
and women stayed out of it that's not
the point of the point I'm bringing up
is that when it comes to you know giving
the issue back to like how conflict
damned like ends feminism I really do
think we're headed back to the 1950s you
you like I've said this before you can
get mad at me all day you can you can go
in the comments you can go on Twitter
and scream Tim Poole law is a bigoted
misogynist and comment what everyone I
don't care when the bombs start dropping
there's no more feminists like okay I'm
being hyper but when it comes to a
global crisis where lives are going to
be lost right you're you're not going to
see the ability right so when it's if by
chance we do go to war with China and
the government's like we need more more
people we're enabling the draft you know
feminists are gonna be like go get em
boys
yep I'll do the laundry your sandwich
sir
go get them exactly I love you you guys
so here's the thing right there there is
a difference you know back in the day it
was women still worked in the war effort
manufacturing and stuff back home mm-hmm
you will see women in combat it has
gotten better there is progress there
will be women doing these things but a
lot of these like ego feminists that are
on you know social media they're just
there to virtue signal exactly yeah look
how virtuous I am yeah
so oh whoa whoa but not when it comes
down to it I'm good so I am so so I will
clarify it you know as we've progressed
and now gotten you know Civil Rights Act
and better equality you now will see top
talented driven women working in the
military and in combat and they're gonna
be better than a lot of guys
yeah like do if there was someone like
you know I was gonna say his name but I
don't want to I don't want to drag
somebody if you have like a short like a
short scrawny little dude you're gonna
be like mm we don't want to send you
like like let's actually look at Captain
America over and over and over right so
so here's the thing back then they
wouldn't to put a woman in the military
right today they will and if you take
like the og Captain America Steve Rogers
before he got the super serum mm-hmm he
would not make the cut right there
probably a lot of women who should have
made the cut back then yeah today that's
what real equality is the opportunity to
to go and not the outcome right these
people are fake right so I want to make
sure we differentiate between like what
feminism is actually obtained and what
it's really all about but I think you're
gonna see it's gonna be like an 8020
rule if if we if if this gets really bad
and it's bad already yeah it's been a
massive economic crash unemployment
could reach 20% don't be surprised when
a lot of the people you knew who were
once progressives feminists are now like
well kind of change in their mind case
in point
Donald Trump wants to close the southern
border and ill hello Mar is praising him
and she says she is in unison with him
that's not that right well I don't know
oh she just no I think I think it's fair
to say she'd probably still be critical
of it I mean her saying that no big deal
all of a sudden what people you know and
I look at like the MSNBC hosts these are
these are not hard these are not strong
men they're not trying to be overly too
respectful - I'm gonna try to elicit an
emotional reaction or strength of mind
both okay mm-hmm like there are some
guys who are physically strong yeah
willfully strong and then there are some
guys who are that kind of dumb but these
are all people who are willing to go on
the front line do it has to be done chop
the wood build the fort and protect
people and then you have these dainty
ivory tower elites from the cities you
know the like pompous nobility with
their pinkies out drinking Glenn oh
heavens
is there someone knocking on the door
and that's like how I imagine like MSNBC
yeah yeah and so you have these you know
foofie foofie men who grew up in perfect
luxury atop their ivory tower yeah and
when the you know the the enemy armies
has come a-knockin all of a sudden
they're like
they spent all their time saying oh the
oafish man at the oval in the Oval
offices Oh
egad and then all of a sudden a bunch of
brutish dudes are banging on the door
saying we're coming for you help me
orange man all I've always said the
Orangemen is good I don't even know what
actions change so I will mention I'm not
trying to rag look if you if you come
out say the right thing you I'll support
you in that it's it's important they're
coming out now at a time of need and
saying the right thing but I think this
you know this story
it's so obvious yeah it's like dude I
could have I could have written to send
on a napkin at a bar and been like in
six months this will have this what is
this woman's gonna do isn't like hand it
off to you to open up bang it was right
so wait until a global crisis happens
then all of a sudden there's like no
actually I want to be fair I actually
think she kind of agrees with us yeah
like I'm saying the same thing like this
view of feminism is under threat I think
she's just approaching it from I guess
I'll call it biased okay I'm a dude
right mm-hmm
so I'm I'm biased a little bit like I'm
gonna be like if you start ragging on
dudes I'm gonna back what well yeah so
like when people say like
all men do this I'll bet hey hey chill
out yeah I can't stand that but this
race now you're Americans but can you
but here's the question I instantly just
think less of the person's opinion but
but here's the question can you
empathize
so like Lydia cases yes I can empathize
if you explain something to me
oh yeah try and understand her position
she sure no I am NOT a woman mean I try
to I tried to do that always yeah right
you know I mean people call me out for
it but I don't care I I part of being a
human is learning the other side of
things and you know gaining compassion
emotional intelligence we talked about
it you know amongst what we even do it
for animals that's why we have laws
protecting animals and being like human
if you if you take a chicken you notice
you get you if you take a chicken and
you like beat it to death you go to jail
yeah you sure can for abusing animal if
you're phony now is that what Trump did
was it I mean even chickens I don't
about chickens well sure oh my god I
have way too much information that just
wanted to come out this is the point I'm
making
we are in an empathy empathetic is a
third word Pathak empathetic
all right least at least most people
think they are no I think I'm talking
about or wanted I'm talking about if you
took all humans you'd find a majority
with the if you were to scale up between
like one to ten of like empathy among
humans it would lean towards empathy
like we are more likely to be yeah yeah
that's why we have laws protecting
animals even though like we kill and eat
chickens yeah yeah you have to do it in
specific ways you really do like except
all underground videos the booting with
their feed of course of course of course
right right
it's okay look let's be honest it's
nuanced you know when it comes to the
factory farm stuff that's a machine
churning and it's messed up that's why I
like to buy organic free-range and even
that's not perfect because sometimes
they just lie but here's the point I'm
making yeah if you took out a chicken
and sour whacking in the head you can
call the cops on you so we do have some
limits I mean for whatever reason thanks
for checking out this segment from the
Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
every Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you